[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend nichts ist überraschend an
dem anstieg der infektionszahlen der
sich jetzt sichtlich beschleunigt exakt
so wird das von experten seit wochen und
monaten vorhergesagt und es ist ja auch
nicht so als wäre das die erste welle
die wir erleben einschließlich der
erkenntnis dass es ein kipp punkt gibt
ab dem die kurve dann sehr plötzlich
sehr steil nach oben geht die zahl der
gemeldeten neuinfektionen liegt heute
bei fast 20.000 die inzidenz bei 95
gestern war sie noch bei 85 vor einer
woche bei 68 von der noch
geschäftsführenden bundesregierung ist
zu dieser entwicklung nicht mehr viel zu
hören dass rk ii hingegen warnt laut und
deutlich im schnitt am höchsten ist die
inzidenz übrigens bei den zehn- bis
14-jährigen von denen die meisten noch
ungeimpft sind manche sagen ja die
kinder werden jetzt durch gesorgt der
fest daran glaubt dass das virus kinder
nichts anhaben können nimmt das hin
thomas münten über die korona lage in
deutschland
mühldorf am inn bayern aktuelle inzidenz
über 450 man sieht davon nichts es gibt
keinen locker und keine geschlossenen
schulen keine verriegelten restaurants
im landratsamt bleiben sie relativ ruhig
weil die lage trotzdem eine andere ist
als vor einem jahr wir haben eine
situation dass hauptsächlich die
ungeimpften momentan die betroffen sind
sind der weit überwiegende teil derer
die sich jetzt infizieren ist ungeübte
der weit überwiegende teil der personen
die ins krankenhaus müssen ist ungewiss
und der weit überwiegende teil derer die
auf der intensivstation landen ist
umgehend die menschen auf der straße
sind genauso gelassen woran die hohe
inzidenz liegt die antworten sind
unterschiedlich
weil immer welche dabei sind die wo sie
einfach nicht impfen lassen und der
kommission was man mag das einfach nicht
über den mächten der besser aber das
andere nicht ich weiß auch soweit ich
kann auf aber dass ich jetzt nicht mehr
raus geht also das kommt dadurch nicht
vor naja ich darf es ist ein mist bild
aber immer noch reiserückkehrern nicht
geimpften jungen also bei den kindern
sind ja die instanzen hohe reise unter
zwölf von daher es wahrscheinlich
gemischt also auf mehr impfungen hoffen
und die bundesweiten pandemie regeln zum
25 november aufheben wie es
gesundheitsminister sparen vorgeschlagen
hat nein sagen heute die
ministerpräsidentinnen aus den 16
ländern der bund muss sicherstellen dass
basis schutzmaßnahmen für herbst und
winter beispielsweise 2 und 3 g
regelungen kontaktdaten erhebungen aha
regeln und ähnliches dass es dafür eine
rechtsgrundlage gibt wenn jedes land das
selbst festlegen muss führt das zu
verwerfungen auch virologen unterstützen
die ansicht der regierungschefs wir
sehen ja heute wie die zahlen sich
bewegen welche richtung sie gehen das
war zu erwarten und es ist zu erwarten
dass es noch weiter nach oben geht mit
den fallzahlen insofern definitiv zum
falschen zeitpunkt und eigentlich nicht
notwendig gewesen
impfungen und lockt downs hätten ein in
europa viel beachteten erfolg gebracht
da sind sich die ministerpräsidenten
sicher weil wir diesen erfolg teilweise
auch schmerzhaft erkauft haben mit
unseren maßnahmen waren wir uns heute
doch sehr einig dass wir kein risiko
eingehen sollten das jetzt mit auslaufen
der pandemischen lage auf einmal uns
rechtsgrundlagen für gegebenenfalls noch
erforderliche maßnahmen fehlen zumindest
diese möglichkeit wollen die
bundesländer auch nach dem 25 november
erhalten denn trotz impfung nicht jedes
konzept verspricht vollen erfolg
bis dahin könnte es dann wohl doch noch
ein halbes jahr dauern
zu dem thema gibt es nachher im
heute-journal update ein interview mit
berlins regierendem bürgermeister
michael müller die korona pandemie hat
uns hierzulande ja auch vor augen
geführt welche defizite deutschland bei
der digitalisierung hat plötzlich rächte
sich dass gesundheitsämter immer noch
mit faxgeräten taktieren oder dass es an
schulen kein vernünftiges wlan gibt wenn
die neue bundesregierung ihr narrativ
fortschrittlich sein zu wollen ernst
nimmt muss sie das thema angehen das ist
parteiübergreifend auch unumstritten nur
wie was muss jetzt geschehen dazu gleich
noch ein gespräch mit sascha lobo doch
zunächst der bericht von dominik nepp
kam
moderne digital so wild sie seien die
ampel fortschritts koalition
modernisierungs chance für eine
digitalisierung unseres landes schneller
und digitaler werden digitalisierung
soll ihre klammer sein zumindest jetzt
nach der wahl im wahlkampf kam das thema
digitalisierung höchstens homöopathisch
vor das fand ich sehr traurig ich wurde
dann aber etwas positiv gestärkt weil am
anfang spd fdp und grüne nicht so recht
zueinander zu finden schienen sich dann
aber geeinigt haben auf eine
fortschritts erzählung und im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert muss jede
fortschritts erzählung zwingend digital
sein konkret verspricht die ampel einen
digital packt 2.0 also mehr geld vom
bund für computer an den schulen die
digitale verwaltung und glasfaserausbau
schnelles internet jetzt aber wirklich
deutschland hinkt hier weit hinterher
nicht erst seit corinna in einer
künftigen regierung sollen die aufgaben
gebündelt werden laut internetwirtschaft
ist das auch dringend nötig wir haben 57
referate und abteilungen innerhalb der
bundesregierung die das nach den begriff
digital im namen tragen aber niemand hat
wirkliche federführung und aus dieser
kakophonie müssen wir jetzt etwas machen
wir müssen einen stimmigen chor und
dafür sorgen dass es jemand gibt ja
vorne steht und er auch sagt wo die
reise hingeht es gab jemanden in der
groko der vorne stand doch wo die reise
hingeht konnte dorothee bär nicht sagen
der staatsministerin für digitales
fehlten budget mitarbeiter macht das
will die fdp jetzt ändern und fordert in
den koalitionsverhandlungen ein eigenes
digitalen ministerium wir haben in den
letzten acht jahren erfahrungen gemacht
wie es nicht funktioniert digitale
kompetenzen zu bündeln ich bin dafür
dass wir bei den neuen aufgaben die sich
stellen auch neue wege gehen und es wird
darum gehen kraftvoll mit einem guten
durchgriff und einem plan einer guten
koordinierung zeitgerecht digital
projekte durchzuführen grüne und spd
sehen das skeptisch sie wollen das
digitale lieber in den bestehenden
ressorts erhalten
es steht für mich in allen ministerien
wenn ich den bund an siehe in allen
verwaltungseinheiten mit auch im
bundestag in der verwaltung muss
digitalisierung zu einer klaren
priorität werden in welcher hinsicht das
dann geregelt wird ob es im ressort im
ressort geht oder nicht das ist eine
frage die sich jetzt nicht stellt
sondern jetzt geht es erstmal um die
inhalte und das wird am ende geklärt
längst werden in berlin nahmen gehandelt
spd chefin saskia esken zum beispiel fdp
generalsekretär volker wissing oder
jemand von außen zum beispiel aus der
digitalwirtschaft ein eigener digital
minister oder eine ministerin es könnte
das erste symbol einer neuen regierung
werden
dabei wollen wir sprechen mit dem
digital experten sascha lobo guten abend
elbow genommen der digitalisierung
verstehen ja viele etwas anderes manche
können den begriff auch nicht so ganz
definieren die einen denken an
funklöcher die anderen an internet was
ist für sie die wichtigste aufgabe in
diesem bereich der entscheidende punkt
die beiden gedanken die sie genannt
haben die stimmen auf jeden fall
digitalisierung ist eigentlich immer
genau das immer genau der fortschritt
der gerade noch nicht da ist deswegen
ist digitalisierung auch immer und
deswegen kann man auch eine aufgabe wie
digitalisierung nicht einfach so
nebenbei erledigen sondern muss sie
wirklich von ganz oben steuern was ist
denn für sie im moment an die meisten
nicht da
das wird niemanden überraschen dass die
digitale infrastruktur das haben wir
wären corona gemerkt mit zu den großen
digitalen katastrophen in deutschland
gehört dass man weder vernünftigen
handyempfang hat wenn man nur wie 300
meter aus der stadtgrenze raus kommt
noch dass man in ganz vielen kleineren
städten in mittleren auch sogar großen
städten für eine vernünftige
geschwindigkeit bekommt und das ist
tatsächlich das große versagen der
letzten neuen bundesregierung merkel so
viele waren es gefühlt ja dass die
digitale infrastruktur derart schlecht
ist auch im internationalen vergleich
übrigens was hätte denn passieren müssen
also jetzt wird ihr allmählich
glasfaserkabel gelegt das ermöglicht ein
sehr schnelles internet was ist da ein
entscheidender stelle in der
vergangenheit schief gelaufenen über
digitalisierung geredet wurde ja immer
also erkannt wurde das problem ja das
ist auch eine sehr gute analyse geredet
wurde immer man hätte sich zum beispiel
vielleicht an den koalitionsvertrag
halten können im koalitionsvertrag der
groko 2017 stand nämlich drin wir
schließen im verlauf ich zitiere der
legislaturperiode alle gewerbegebiete
alle krankenhäuser und alle schulen ans
gigabit internet an das stand er als
zitat drin und wenn frau merkel jetzt
nicht schnell eine zeitmaschine erfindet
und in der zeit zurückreist dann glaube
ich ist das ziemlich drastisch
gescheitert ich bin der meinung man
hätte sehr viel früher bessere
rahmenbedingungen setzen müssen man
hätte sehr viel früher einen
funktionierenden markt aufstellen müssen
und vor allem eine sehr große förderung
für glasfaser herkommen
liegt vielleicht auch daran dass das
eben auch ein thema ist naja der politik
sind viele juristen unterwegs aber wenn
es um digitalisierung geht braucht man
eigentlich programmierer hacker nerds
und die sind vielleicht auch nicht so
viel in ministerien unterwegs
das würde ich so nicht sagen es soll
auch juristen geben die sich mit der
digitalisierung auskennen und manchmal
kann es sogar und nicht also im weg
stehen wenn man zu sehr fachlich auf ein
thema drauf guckt aus meiner sicht dass
das hauptproblem gewesen dass frau
merkel die digitalisierung immer als
politische verhandlungsmasse begriffen
hat will sagen sie hat dann am ende
irgendwie dann doch dazu geneigt das zu
tauschen meinetwegen gegen die
pendlerpauschale oder wegen irgendwas
mit dem euro und wenn man die
digitalisierung nicht als
gesamtgesellschaftliche riesige aufgabe
die die nicht verhandelbar ist begreift
dann hat man genau das problem vor dem
wir jetzt stehen wir sind in ganz vielen
bereichen katastrophe zurück zum
beispiel auch bei verwaltung in anderen
ländern passiert das alles längst in
digital da stellt sich keiner mehr an
und versuchten termin auf irgendeinem
berliner bürger am zu bekommen aber ein
problem mit der politik ist ja auch dass
es um zuständigkeiten geht und da ist ja
zum beispiel auch dorothee bär als
digitalen zuständige der bundesregierung
letztendlich gescheitert weil sie hatte
kein wirkliches budget und das
wirtschaftsministerium das
innenministerium das verkehrsministerium
die haben sich da auch alle konkurrenz
gemacht kann man so etwas mit einem
digital ministerium bekämpfenden
anführungsstrichen aus meiner sicht auf
jeden fall ich würde sehr stark für ein
digital ministerium plädieren und zwar
für ein richtiges ich schätze frau bär
aber sie konnte ihren job nicht richtig
erledigen schon weil sie kein richtiges
budget hatte und keinen großen stab eine
staatsministerin die sie war im
kanzleramt ist eben nur eine kleine
variante eines ministeriums ein digital
minister eine digital ministerin halte
ich für absolut unverzichtbar um die
digitalisierung voranzubringen das ist
anderen eventuell aber auch erst mal ein
ins schaufenster stellen also konstantin
von notz der grünen-politiker der
sicherlich nicht im verdacht steht sich
mit digitalisierung nicht auszukennen
oder das ausbrennen sind zu wollen er
warnt davor das sagt ja machen wir
erstmal eine neue bürokratie und bauen
drei jahre neues ministerium auf und in
der zwischenzeit passiert nichts und es
entstehen irgendwelche doppelstrukturen
das kann schwierig werden mit seinem
digitalen ministerium das mag sein
vielleicht ist das aber eine etwas zu
binnensicht ich geäußerte meinung ich
glaube dass das symbol extrem wichtig
ist denn das symbol eines eigenen
ministeriums das geht eben auch an die
anderen häuser und wir haben eine
vielzahl von digitalen projekten die in
der letzten legislatur katastrophal
gescheitert sind die idee wolle zum
beispiel die den digitalen führerschein
hätte ergeben sollen eine woche vor der
wahl angekündigt er kurz nach der wahl
wieder zurückgezogen wunder und das ist
auch daran gescheitert dass da so viele
häuser zuständig waren und so viele
zuständigkeiten sich gegenseitig
blockiert haben dass das symbol jetzt
hat einer den hut auf jetzt hat eine den
hut auf dass das glaube ich zu sehr viel
klügeren projekt verläufen führen würde
sascha lobo und danken für das gespräch
wer gern mehr hintergründe zum thema
finden sie bei uns natürlich wie immer
auch online auf zdf heute.de und jetzt
zu den nachrichten der konflikt um
taiwan spitzt sich zu als us präsident
biden hat taiwan militärische
unterstützung zugesichert sollte es von
china angegriffen werden dazu habe die
us-regierung eine verpflichtung so
beiden bei einer bürgersprechstunde in
baltimore er bekräftigte allerdings auch
dass die usa keinen konflikt mit china
suchten peking betrachtet taiwan als
abtrünnige provinz das chinesische
außenministerium warnte die usa vor sich
in innere angelegenheiten des landes
einzumischen
die nato hat beim treffen der
verteidigungsminister in brüssel einen
milliardenschweren
innovationsfonds angekündigt der solle
die neuesten technologien und
fähigkeiten für die alliierten
sicherstellen wie generalsekretär
stoltenberg erklärte thema war auch die
zusammenarbeit zwischen nato und bieten
die usa unterstützen laut
verteidigungsminister osten eine
stärkere und fähige europäische
verteidigung die mit der nato vereinbar
ist
über eine solche europäische
verteidigung haben bei einem telefonat
auf frankreichs präsident makro und
us-präsident beiden sich ausgetauscht
wie es nach dem gespräch aus dem weißen
haus hieß bei dem telefonat ging es auch
um das geplante persönliche treffen der
beiden das nun für ende des monats in
rom vorgesehen ist dort findet am 30 und
31 oktober der g20 gipfel statt
die crew des deutschen seenotretter
schiff seabed streit darf mit mehr als
400 migranten an bord in sizilien
anlegen die italienischen behörden
hätten ihr den hafen pozzallo an
zugewiesen teilte die hilfsorganisation
mit die migranten seien am sonntag und
montag bei mehreren einsätzen aus seenot
gerettet worden
kurz nach aufnahme der
koalitionsgespräche haben in berlin
tausende anhänger der frau des future
bewegung für einen entschlossenen der
wenn klimaschutz demonstriert unter dem
motto ihr lasst uns keine wahl forderten
die streikenden unter anderem einen
verbindlichen kohleausstieg bis
spätestens 2030 neben der haupt
demonstration hatten sich auch vor den
parteizentralen von spd fdp und grünen
demonstrieren der zu blockadeaktionen
versammelt
in brüssel ist der eu gipfel zu ende
gegangen die probleme bleiben natürlich
nach außen mit belarus dessen diktator
versuchte die eu mit flüchtlingen zu
erpressen die an ihren grenzen aussetzt
und im inneren geht der streit mit polen
und ungarn weiter da geht es ans
eingemachte der eu an ihre werte an ihre
prinzipien und das erfülle sie mit sorge
sagte angela merkel für die das heute
vermutlich der letzte europäische gipfel
war von ihren europäischen kollegen und
kolleginnen wurde sie heute offiziell
verabschiedet man merkte dass sie in dem
kreis tatsächlich vermisst werden wird
die blume ersten worte fand der
präsident des europäischen rats michelle
er sagte zu ihr sie sei ein monument der
europäische rat ohne angela ist wie home
ohne den vatikan oder paris ohne
eifelturm
das abschiedsgeschenk war dann
allerdings wieder im nüchternen eu style
berichtet anne gellinek
europa ist nicht glamourös merkel ist es
auch nicht insofern passte der abschied
den die kanzlerin am morgen von den
anderen 26 regierungs chefs und
chefinnen
eine statue die das europa gebäude in
brüssel symbolisieren soll und ein paar
minuten stehender applaus nur fotos kein
video
typisch für merkel ist ihre
bescheidenheit sie hat sich zwar nicht
geärgert über das viele lob heute beim
gipfel aber angenehm war es ihr auch
nicht
frau merkel war so eine kompromiss-
maschine dh sehr oft wenn es einfach
nicht weitergehen dann hat die angelangt
und dann kam sie sagt sie
und dann haben es fertiggebracht
trotzdem noch ambitionen zu haben
merkels letzter eu gipfel gibt noch mal
alles keine harmonie stattdessen lange
zähe debatten mit nachtsitzung ohne
ergebnisse merkel sieht europa in einer
situation die mir durchaus auch sorgen
macht wir haben halt auch eine reihe von
ungelösten problemen und die baustellen
für meinen nachfolger sind groß dass sie
sich sorgen machen muss zum beispiel
beim streit mit polen um die
rechtsstaatlichkeit liegt auch an merkel
selbst jahrelang hat sie lieber den eu
laden zusammengehalten als harte kritik
an ungarn oder polen zu äußern als
osteuropa verstehen hielt sie ihre hand
über viktor orban und matthäus morawski
auch bei diesem gipfel sie bremst den
appetit der mitgliedstaaten polen sofort
eu-geld zu kürzen der niederländer
unzufrieden
eine große gruppe von mitgliedstaaten
sieht das was die polnische regierung
tut sehr kritisch wir machen uns große
sorgen weil das auch mit dem
funktionieren des binnenmarkts zu tun
hat und noch ein thema hat merkel trotz
aller versuche nie in den griff bekommen
die flüchtlingspolitik auf ihrem letzten
gipfel läuft die debatte noch einmal aus
dem ruder anlass ist der belarussische
diktator lukaschenko der seit wochen
flüchtlinge richtung europa schickt zehn
länder wollen zäune bauen und von der eu
finanzieren lassen der streit darüber
gleitet ab ins grundsätzliche
nie hat die eu es geschafft sich zu
einigen auch wenn die osteuropäer nicht
mitspielten zu den zäunen zumindest gibt
es eine klare ansage
es gibt schon lange eine klare
übereinkunft zwischen kommission und
parlament wir finanzieren weder
stacheldraht kloft mauern
das bauen eines eu asylsystems ein job
für den nachfolger merkels abschied nach
16 jahren europa schnörkellos
habe ich jetzt noch mal eins mit
wirtschaft
lieferengpässe belasten die wirtschaft
der chip mangel ist eines der großen
themen auch für die autoindustrie und
jetzt ist auch noch aluminium in den
schlagzeilen frank bethmann was könnte
da drohen ja ein noch viel größeres
problem bereits im januar droht das
wichtige metall auszugehen china als
fast alleiniger lieferant drosselt die
magnesium produktion ohne magnesium aber
kein aluminium und so steuern die
autobauer auf den nächsten gravierenden
mangel zu in der fertigung bei vielen
bauteilen ob bei fähigen ob in teilen
des herkömmlichen motor blogs oder auch
in den gehäusen von elektromotoren
steckt aluminium drin und in e autos
gleich viermal so viel während in einem
verbrenner im schnitt zwischen 90 und
150 kilogramm verbaut werden können es
in einem elektrofahrzeug in der spitze
bis zu 600 kilogramm sein der grund ist
naheliegend weil die batterien sehr
schwer sind wird an vielen stellen im
auto stahl durch das leichtere aluminium
ersetzt für die kunden sind das gleich
in doppelter hinsicht eher schlechte
nachrichten je nach modell und
ausstattung drohen lange wartezeiten und
die autos dürften auch deutlich teurer
werden denn dort wo mangel herrscht wie
jetzt beim aluminium steigen die preise
im jahresverlauf verteuerte sich das
papier metall bereits um 60 prozent
tendenz weiter steigend erst der
chronische ship mangel nun die
beunruhigende aluminium knappheit die
erholung der autoindustrie gerät immer
mehr ins stocken der dax davon heute
unbeeindruckt geht mit einem plus von 70
punkten ins wochenende
frank bethmann vielen dank gerne zur
fußball-bundesliga hat mainz heute abend
augsburg zu gast und kurz vor schluss
steht es 4 zu 1 bei der bahnrad wm in
rom gab es heute für das deutsche team
drei weitere medaillen zwei im sprint
immerhin zugewandt gold und lea-sophie
friedrich selber oder im 1000 meter
zeitfahren holte joachim eilers bronze
der wm titel ging an den niederländer
jeffrey hochland
in den usa ist es bei dreharbeiten zu
einem western film einen tragischen
zwischenfall gegeben der us schauspieler
alec baldwin hat in einer szene mit
einer requisiten waffe geschossen eine
kamera frau wurde getötet und der
regisseur des films verletzt wie es dazu
kommen konnte ist noch unklar
normalerweise werden an film setzte nur
platzpatronen verwendet die polizei
ermittelt gegen baldwin richten sich
momentan keine vorwürfe der schauspieler
zeigte sich schockiert über den vorfall
udo zimmermann star komponist der ddr
und einer der führenden zeitgenössischen
komponisten ist nach langer krankheit im
alter von 78 jahren gestorben
mehr als zehn jahre leitete er die oper
leipzig dann noch deutsche oper berlin
seine eigenen werke die die weiße rose
über die geschwister scholl feierten
auch international erfolge als dirigent
gastierte er bei renommierten orchestern
wie den wiener und berliner
philharmoniker
jeder kennt ihn den schrei von edvard
munch ein bild zum nachfühlen was wohl
auch einen großen teil seiner
popularität ausmacht in vielen bildern
des norwegischen künstlers spielen angst
und zweifel eine rolle freude ist eher
selten wie hier bei seinem bild tanz des
lebens obwohl auch in dieser szene etwas
unheilvolles liegt und so porträtierte
munk sich selbst als junger mann anfang
30 durch dessen leben da schon viel tod
und trauer gezogen waren jung selbst
litt an depressionen
aber er wurde norwegens grösster
künstler dem nun in oslo ein neues
spektakuläres museum gewidmet wird ein
stück architektur kunst des spanischen
büros es studio hereros zu dessen beim
inhabern der deutsche jens richter
gehört sie haben nun das weltweit größte
museum für einen einzelnen künstler
gebaut so hat halt die berichtet
es ist der letzte schrei
ein gebäude verneigt sich vor edward
moore
die norwegische hauptstadt oslo baut
ihrem lieblingsmaler eines der größten
museen der welt
kompost ist ein fantastisches gebäude
ein museum das inspiriert
cooles gebäude in dem die kunst von
edward muss sehr stylisch präsentiert
wird
ganz schrecklich ich verstehe nicht wie
man die erlaubnis bekommen hat es zu
bauen das sieht aus wie eine leitplanke
der bau nicht unumstritten
13 geschosse für die kunst
umgerechnet rund 280 millionen euro hat
das fulminante kunsthaus gekostet
das museum hat mehr zu bieten als kunst
neben den ausstellungssälen gibt es orte
für konzerte und vorträge ein kino
restaurants und cafés sowie eine
spektakuläre
aussichtsplattformen
spektakulär nicht nur die kunst sondern
auch der bau selbst das neue museum ein
kühler und durchaus gruber riesen rahmen
mit einer fassade aus aluminium paneelen
die die wertvollen exponate vor licht
und sonne schützen
und zusätzlich schaffen diese parallele
natürlich auch einen sehr hohen
wiedererkennungswert sie sind gewählt
die sind perforiert und
wie die wellen des fjords gehen diese
kurvten paneele in der gebäudefassade
vertikal hoch und ganz oben im gebäude
werden die paneele weggenommen damit man
einen freien ausblick auf das gesamte
umland hat
mehr als sein schreien sein berühmtestes
werk kein einzelstück etwas monates
mehrfach gemalt
liebe und tod angst und einsamkeit die
wichtigsten themen des norwegers
sichtbar in den
27.000 gemälden drucken
und zeichnungen
[Musik]
edmund ist ein großer künstler und ein
wichtiger teil unserer identität dieses
museum ist ein statement ein imperativ
der für die bedeutung von munk seinem
werk und die rolle der kunst in der
gesellschaft steht
das
spiegelt vielleicht weniger das
melancholische wesen des künstlers
wieder als eine bedeutung für norwegen
das war es von uns weiter geht es mit
der heute show oder 0 15 gibt es dann
unser heutigen update mit einer sekte
wir haben noch viele seen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend wäre es bei uns in
mitteleuropa ja richtig kalt geworden
ist morgen nur mit höchsttemperaturen
von zehn grad liegen die werte am
mittelmeer noch bei 25 und 30 grad das
sind sommerliche werte und auch das
wasser des mittelmeers ist noch warm so
können sich aus so harmlos erscheinenden
regen gebieten durchaus nochmal unwetter
tief zusammenbauen das passiert
wahrscheinlich anfang der kommenden
woche und zwar über dem zentralen und
östlichen mittelmeer für unser wetter
hier in deutschland ist das hoch quentin
burgi am wochenende verantwortlich das
sieht nämlich in den nächsten 24 stunden
von frankreich zu uns rein dahinter wird
es deutlich bilden auch angetrieben von
den kräftigen tief bei island heute
nacht fällt noch etwas regen in der
mitte und es gibt einzelne schauer in
norddeutschland sonst ist es häufig
locker bewölkt oder klar und dann wird
es kalt dann sinken die temperaturen
hier den mittelgebirgen auch in
süddeutschland auf plus 3 bis minus 1
grad da droht also überall bodenfrost
sonst bleibt die nacht milder bei 9 bis
4 grad und morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen ganz ähnlich wie
heute zwischen 7 grad in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und 13 grad auf den
ostfriesischen inseln und am rhein das
wird ein sehr freundlicher samstag sonne
und wolken wechseln sich ab und
besonders sonnig wird zwischen dem
alpenrand und dem schwarzwald noch kommt
der winter so aus nördlichen richtungen
aber das ändert sich schon am sonntag
dann gibt es einen wind aus südlichen
richtungen es wird mit werten von 9 bis
14 grad auch schon ein kleines bisschen
milder nach nehmen und uns strahlt die
sonne am sonntag und ganz ähnlich
startet auch die neue woche etwas
wechselhafter gibt es danach weiter
guten abend